Hello everyone, this is Frank Di Freitas and welcome to a special broadcast of HoloTalk.
So I would like to take this opportunity to thank you for inviting me and Mario Andres into your homes, your schools, and your businesses.
We're going to do this broadcast so that you can learn a little bit about lasers and holography.
Holograms can appear so real that sometimes you are fooled into thinking that what you are seeing is right in front of you.
You may wish to reach out and try and touch the image in a hologram.
But your hand just passes right through.
And advertising comerciales.
You may buy a box of cereal and see a hologram on the box.
If you wear jeans, you may find holograms on your clothes.
So that they are not counterfeited.
And in museums you may see holograms as fine art.
Where artists use the three-dimensional properties of holography to express themselves.
Now at this point you may be asking what do holograms and lasers have in common.
Well the truth is you do not need a laser to see a hologram, but you need a laser to make one.
And some day you may find yourself working with lasers as your job.
With holography, we use lasers to make holograms.
A laser provides the special light needed in order to make the hologram.
There are gas lasers.
When electricity is applied to the gas in the tube, it begins to glow.
And it is reflected back and forth between two mirrors that are on the ends of the tube.
And exits through one of the mirrors as a laser beam.
Which is made specially for holograms.
Recently we found a new way to make holograms.
And we do not require the very expensive gas lasers.
We use very inexpensive lasers called laser diodes.
And we have made holograms using a laser pointer.
Because it opens the field up to very, very many people.
I know we didn't have a lot of time to cover very many things.
But I hope it at least make you a little more interested in lasers and holography.
And on your own, you will search out information on the field.
So I would like to thank Mario Andres Muniz for doing the translations for this show.
Good day.